what Alexandria Tate will spend the next
month behind bars in Romania to losing
the latest appeal against his detention
taking his brother Tristan are being
held as part of a investigation into
rape and human trafficking or speaking
outside Court Andrew Taylor he's done
nothing wrong
[Music]
well the pack is still with me plus
joining me now is the lawyer for the
Tate Brothers Tina glandian who is in
Romania well welcome to Ms Daniel I
really appreciate you joining me where
are we with this case it seems like
every now and again this pops up back on
television with them being remanded for
further time how long can that process
continue before a charging decision is
made
under Romanian law they have up to 180
days which is in 30-day increments so
every time there's a 30-day detention
order they're allowed to renew their
request and have it extended for an
additional 30 days but not to exceed 180
days okay you've taken on this case
Andrew Tate has been repeatedly uh
bellowing his innocence as he's been LED
in and out of of these Court hearings
and so on
do you believe them do you believe that
he and his brother are innocent
at this point Pierce they've had this
investigation going since April we're
now February and there are not even
charges filed against them so this is a
huge Injustice the way we see it they
should not be detained at this point we
think it's now crossed over to the point
where it's violating international human
rights law because the deprivation of of
your Liberty pre-trial is the most
severe form of punishment a state can
impose and that's what they've done in
this case and they've had a very lengthy
investigation with the government's
resources they've been analyzing and
looked looking at all of their devices
since April When They seized everything
and here we are February and charges
aren't filed so I think there's
absolutely no evidence that's been
presented
and that's our position what is I mean
how are your clients at the moment how
is Andrew Tate dealing with
incarceration and I interviewed him just
before Christmas we had a long
wide-ranging interview and once again I
was struck by the phenomenal
following that he has online
particularly with young men you know he
has an enormous following there
you and I know this has been whipped up
now by that Community into a huge
framing of a narrative this is complete
Injustice there are others who think
this has been a long time coming that
he's a bad human being and that he's
going to face very serious charges and
that will be the last we see of him
um but how is he faring right now given
that at the moment he's in this limbo
land of no charging but being held uh in
incarceration
the brothers are both very strong
they're resilient and they're holding up
but obviously the conditions are not
good they're in a Romanian jail cell and
they've been detained for a very lengthy
period at this point they have limited
access to their attorneys um it's it's
not a good condition for them
you've obviously as far as sorry please
finish
I was just gonna I was gonna say to your
second point
their controversial public figures but
that's not a crime and at this point we
have not been provided any proof that
they've committed any crimes nor have
they even been charged so I would ask
that people presume them in a sent as
they are
do they feel that they are being tried
in the court of public opinion
as divided as you know I think they have
a big following but at the end of the
day yes I think there is a lot of
information in the public I think
there's a lot of false allegations in
the public
I think some evidence has now been put
forth again I don't want to comment too
much on the facts of the case since
there is an ongoing criminal
investigation however I think there has
been evidence put out
um videos and other statements for the
public to see what the supposed state of
the evidence actually is
it's been interesting to watch Andrew
Tate's Twitter feed in particular that
he's continued to tweet is he doing that
himself has he got people doing that for
him and how do you feel from a legal
point of view is it is it a wise tactic
to continue to do that on social media
when you're being held in custody by the
remaining authorities
well again he doesn't have access so
he's not doing anything directly and
what's being put out is is on his
accounts and
I'm not going to speak as to you know
the source of of the posts and what's
being put out but I think again as of
now he's not charged with anything and
he's free to comment
publicly if he wishes to yeah they've
obviously we know that They seized uh
nearly three and a half million pounds
in cash 11 luxury sports cars guns and
other weapons or any of the things that
have been seized from the property are
they in themselves acts of law breaking
just the possession of any of these
things
to my knowledge they're not I think if
they were they would have been charged
with crimes again they they had the
initial search in April and it's
February it's been 10 months and no
charges have been filed whatsoever
we have an ongoing criminal
investigation for which this is a
preventative detention which is why
they're in custody again this is the
most severe form of punishment I don't
think it's Justified under these
circumstances where the prosecution
hasn't set forth enough evidence to
charge them and yet they are detained
and it's being prolonged
but you do accept of course that if the
women who've come forward here is part
of the investigation if they're telling
the truth these are very serious
allegations against your clients which
could lead to charging and if a led to
charging could lead potentially to Long
prison centers if found guilty
certainly the the crimes that issue are
very serious crimes and I think Pierce
actually it was on your show when you
interviewed Tate several months ago he
made very strong statements about his
position on rape and he condemned rape
and he said it was disgusting was I'm
pretty sure the word he used and he said
he thought that somebody who does that
deserves the death penalty so there's no
question that these are serious charges
and even in his own words they're very
serious charges there just isn't any
evidence that they committed these
crimes but you know we've also had tapes
which have emerged in the last few weeks
of him talking about rape to a woman in
a pretty unsavory manner so what is your
response to that
can you I'm sorry I didn't catch that
you said what surfaced did there have
been various tapes of surfaced in part
of media investigations in the last few
weeks including Andrew Tate talking
about rape to a woman in a pretty
unsavory manner so what would your
reaction be to that
first of all I think the authenticity of
anything that is presented through the
media as opposed to turned over to the
defense needs to be questioned because
material is edited and it's it's easily
manipulated so first I would say that
secondly I don't think certain text
messages
um you know there are I'm not here to
judge or to talk to people's desires or
fetishes but certainly somebody could
easily set someone up by saying they
like they have certain fantasies they
want
certain things done to them or said to
them and so there's a lot that goes into
you can't take a text message out of
context you first have to know first of
all the entire context of it and what
the background is there needs to be
explanation so I think you have to keep
all of that in mind when you're seeing
something in the media we do and we have
to give your mind also the judge's
reasoning for all this I explained on
the 20th of January that they viewed the
particular dangerousness of the
defendants and their capacity to
identify victims with increased
vulnerability in such a better life
opportunities so all of this has to be
taken into account but it goes on and as
you rightly say at the moment there have
been no charges against your clients and
until or if that point arrives we're in
a world of allegation not actual charges
correct and right now exactly there's a
presumption of innocence
to and that every accused has and that
attaches from the time you're even
charged and here we're not even there
they haven't even charged them with
crimes so any sort of comments as to the
their alleged dangerousness there's no
there's no evidence of that there isn't
even a presumption of that they need to
be presumed innocent and that's that
hasn't happened in this case there's
really a lack of evidence and they are
being detained unlawfully at this point
I appreciate you joining me thank you
very much indeed
thank you pierce